on
[Musique]
je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est impossible de vivre sans téléphone
c'est la chose que je fais le plus dans
la journée je suis tout au dessus mais
je n'en ai pas en maintenant qu'il
commence à utiliser des smartphones j'y
vais tous les jours j'ai obligé
puisqu'il ya des filles qui marot c est
vraiment vital on va dire
j'ai déjà en biais des personnes sur les
réseaux sociaux et surtout avec sur le
phénomène des gens posent bad
donc ce sont les gens qui ont l'air
d'avoir une vie parfaite
voilà leur petit déjeuner tous les
matins on dirait que c'est des petits
déj de l'hôtel tout ça et à partir du
moment où on est conscient que c'est pas
la réalité bien apparent vient on peut
pas à se sentir mal parce que voilà il
faut s'accepter comme on est et puis des
photos ça reflète pas vraiment quelqu'un
ya souvent de belles figures niche a des
yeux bleus il ya un an en europe en
juillet par l'image que les autres
contenus ou qu'on a nommé où se focalise
sur le physique
et quand il voit par exemple une fille
le jeune homme a plus beaucoup plus
belles physiquement et b qui sont mal
dans leur peau
ça m'est déjà arrivé une fois sur
instagram j'ai publié une photo on m'a
dit t'es moche ou tu ne devrais pas être
dessus de son cadet parole des petites
des petits enfantillages le pire réseau
social sai t as qu à ce que c'est un
réseau social ou un ppt et aux
politiques à sion anonymement et on
m'avait insulté dessus on m'avait dit
que j'étais les deux on m'avait posé des
questions très privées et cette
indication qu'il veut venir que de
personnes qui me connaissait et le fait
que ce soit posée anonymement ça fait
mal parce qu'on sait pas qui ça vient
mais ça vient quand même avec les
réseaux sociaux on n'a pas de pause
en fait dès qu'on est harcelé ça
continue chez nous ça continue tout le
temps on n'est même pas à l'école mais
on reçoit toujours des insultes donc je
pense que ça pousse encore en plus au
suicide
on me reproche des fois mon cousin
surtout il me reproche mais mettez
jamais fin si jamais ce qui se passe etc
mais moi je préfère ne pas recevoir ce
genre de choses là pour ne pas m'abrutir
avec ça ici au tout qu'on n'a pas fait
aussi au qc ca
[Musique]
aussi
les conflits de communication entre
parents et adolescents
ce sont des réseaux sociaux la sexualité
de l'enfant quoi d'autre encore
l'homosexualité par exemple la peur de
d'être rejetée parfois ce genre de
petites choses et parfois on va pas tout
confié parce qu'on a peur de la réaction
du parent ou des parents je sens pendant
l'adolescence donc la communication avec
mes parents un peu compliqué j'ai
l'impression que même s'il essaie de me
comprendre et ne le comprennent pas
vraiment de temps en temps c'est de ma
faute parce que même moi même j'ai ce
parce que je veux je suis un peu par
adulte fait je pense que vous pouvez
faire vous défend nous apprend l'exemple
de personnes qui vivent qu'avec leur
pain sans internet sans la télé sans
rien du tout ben et se fie à ce que nos
parents disent oui nous on absorbe les
informations
d'ailleurs et l'éducation et les valeurs
et les principes
moi j'essaye de l'associé de l'assimiler
avec ce départ m en semaine et vous
donne
tu m'as dit souvent avec informations
pense que j différentes
on met des tout le temps je suis ici je
suis ça je suis égoïste de la famille en
importance pour moi parce que les
familles en iran et en fait presque
revenir pour moi c est qu il est devenu
conseiller
moi je me retiens de m'exprimer d'enfer
de les contredire parce que je sais
qu'ils ont le bon exemple pour moi même
si quelquefois c'est vraiment difficile
et que bon on s'énerve un peu
je reviens rue du fort notre famille une
famille parfaite mais
ça n'existe pas dans toutes les familles
qui a forcément un défaut peut-être que
même j'aurais été dans ma famille parent
fait ça ce serait pas bien passé
certains parents quand ils ont des
discussions en famille on dit par
exemple une exposition makoum et au p 10
mais c'est un cheval et aux sédiments du
gie peur de le dire quand est ce que je
pourrais le dire est ce qu'ils vont
l'accepter
ils se disent mon jeu ce n'est pas
normal pour certains qui sont
catholiques ou qui ont une religion
particulière ils doivent se dire que ce
n'est pas bien c'est mal j'ai jamais
pensé que c'était quelque chose pas
naturel qui ne devait pas exister
c'est vraiment de la discrimination pour
moi c'est comme dire à quelqu'un que tu
devrais pas être noir que c'est mieux
d'être blanc ça n'a aucun rapport
je vois pas pourquoi ça dérange les gens
si eux mêmes ne sont pas homosexuels se
sont juste pas leurs affaires
déjà la martinique c'est pas à combler
d'autres pays c'est quand même payer qui
est beaucoup fermé il ya on n'est pas
400 milles donc les mentalités évoluent
très très très lentement
en plus la population est vieillissante
moi j'ai toujours tendance à dire que
ces anciennes générations qui justement
en perpétue puces et ses critiques
envers les homosexuels ou el himma
roumec on vous appelle ici les mac ou
mais un an
donc bon moi je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on passe au un peu autre chose on en
quand on a grandi a eu la loi du mariage
pour tous donc je pense que on accepte
majoritairement les homosexuels parce
que
on vit avec eux et puis bon nation l'a
suivi tout leur combat je n'ai rien
contre les homosexuels
mais il ya certaines lois et je ne suis
pas d'accord comme le mariage pour tous
pour moi le mariage ça doit être une
femme et un homme et non une femme une
femme ou un homme ou un homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis déjà senti avec quelqu'un veut
pas qu'une amourette ça change quelqu'un
je pense on doit bien peu plus mature
grandi ça m'a fait comprendre qu'on peut
pas non plus donner par exemple like sa
confiance à n'importe qui n'importe
quand j'ai mis un garçon vivant en
france mais on s'est dit que c'était pas
possible parce que la [__] soin
d'indiquer que je rencontrerai une autre
personne mais j'étais quand même une
fois moins d'eau
ce
j'ai déjà abordé cinq j'ai déjà pensé
mais on n'a jamais fait moi même j'avoue
j'avais pratiqué c'est normal c'est la
sexualité c'est quelque chose que
peut-être que tu va partager avec l'âme
soeur ou quelqu'un d'autre je ne sais
pas mais je trouve que c'est normal
c'est l'asie cela de licence le fait de
voir ses copines nous raconter leur
expérience
ça c'est le truc qu'il faut faire avec
un gain de 4-2 mais n'en n'ont en
général ont déjà les garçons s'en vante
tout le temps il parle de sable des
filles avec qui ils ont eu des rapports
voilà il s'en vend pour eux c'est une
fierté à des phénomènes assez désolant
comme la prostitution des filles ce
qu'on appelle ici le kpn est en fait ce
sont des filles qui se prostituent pour
avoir des choses n'est pas forcément de
l'argent mais des biens
un matériel matériel des biens matériels
et voilà comme des téléphones
voilà c'est assez désolant donc le sexe
c'est vrai que ça une place assez
importante ici de manière assez
péjoratif c'est trop curieux à la légère
en fait pour moi j'ai opté par
conscience des risques que peuvent
engendrer la sexualité je ne dit pas aux
gens de ne pas rendre à sexuelles et des
foyers nous faire attention
enfin
oh
on
jd à coup son ami de l'alcool des
cigarettes de la drogue comme la plupart
des jeunes après six niveaux de jeunesse
c'est un peu un effet de mode de rentrer
dedans voilà la fumée tous les matins
avant d'aller au lycée où toutes les
soirées qui enfin où les gens consomment
est vraiment dans l'excès et surtout au
niveau des drogues particulièrement le
cannabis ça n'apporte que des problèmes
ont manqué que pull est en place il ya
pis le chômage est la violence augmente
les mets entre aussi donc ça ne rapporte
que du négatif au sein de la jeunesse
banalisent l'alcool on en fait quelque
chose d'attractif par exemple sont cités
mais bon les dsp acceptera bon c'est
quelque chose de rouge c'est sucré etc
on banalise vraiment ça moi je trouve
que c'est dommage parce que l'alcool ça
détruit pas mal de du rhône
[Musique]
non je suis pas facile oui je suis allé
au lycée
oui mais bon ma scolarité je ne suis pas
bon je me sens bien à l'école
je n'ai aucun problème avec personne je
m'entends bien avec tout le monde je
suis très extravertie j'ai la
communication très facile et ça me
permet de m'ouvrir aux gens de parler ce
qui nous rend l année ce sont nos amis
la présence de nos amis les courants
nous mais je pense qu'il faudrait
changer la pédagogie pour un certain
professeur peut-être moins de théorie
plus de pratique depuis que je suis
arrivé ici j'ai beaucoup changé de
comportement
je suis devenu plus discret plus calme
et voilà ça mais ça ne me dérange pas ça
m'apporte que des bonnes choses
[Musique]
aussi
moi je ne me sens pas français parce que
je pense je suis jamais leur fasse mais
la plupart des autres et qui vont france
se sentent un peu discriminés quand
j'étais allé en france il ya deux ans
peut-être
on m'avait demandé si j'habitais dans
une cabane près de créer du sable dans
les cocotiers
donc franchement je me demandais c'était
une blague mais c'était vraiment la
personne était très sérieuse je suis né
en france pour moi mais j'ai vécu en
martinique j'ai fait ma jambe entier
dont j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
comme la culture le la nourriture le
chant la danse le ballet danse
traditionnelle donc je me dis je suis
martiniquais
je me sens française mais je me sens
française de martinique
je ne me sens pas française la france
metropolit et quand on a eu un ex
président qui dit que tous les français
ont des ancêtres gaulois pour moi ça
nous ça nous accueillent pas en fait
dans cette france métropolitaine on se
sent pas français de france
beaucoup de choses que l'on veut faire
de la vie wallon veut étudier ne sont
pas disponibles en martinique wallons
sont disponibles mais non pas un très
bon niveau n'ont pas une très bonne
réputation
beaucoup de jeunes martiniquais ont
beaucoup d'ambition devenir médecins
avocats écrivains acteurs réalisateurs
photographes et non je pense qu'on a on
a beaucoup d'ambitions manque justement
de ressources pour les réaliser pour
concrétiser nos projets je voudrais
partir étudier autre part qu'en
martinique
j'aime voyager j'aime voir de nouveaux
endroits j'aime pas rester sur place si
je pouvais partir c'est ce que déjà une
opportunité pour mes études j'ai
toujours voulu partir de la martinique
même pas forcément parler en france mais
juste partir parce que pour moi c'est
trop petit pour moi on n'a pas
grand-chose à faire dedans en fait mais
depuis peut-être cette année je me suis
dit qu'il faudrait peut-être que je
reste le temps de mes études parce que
jusqu'à dans suis très proche de ma
famille et je pense que par six ans en
mai un ami ou un colocataire a par
exemple je me retrouvais vite perdu
[Musique]
dans dix ans j'aurais 27 ans alors je me
vois diplômés éventuellement avec un
travail sp1 voilà et j'espère avec un
premier enfant parce que voilà comment
c'est trop tard ben peut-être graphie
c'est bien un truc
avec l'arrêt tout sans enfant moi je
m'imagine avec eux mon mari avec mes
deux enfants mon métier j'avais deux
métiers un vrai métier et c'est dans un
mois dans dix ans je pense que
j'idéalise un peu mon avenir mais vaut
mieux des alizés parce que on dans un
monde maintenant qui est très malheureux
presque
je préfére idéalisé mon avenir pour moi
dans dix ans je me vois évidemment dans
ma grosse voiture avec une vie familiale
stable mais j'aimerais devenir peut-être
directeur des ressources humaines à
louer nus ou alors travail à l'onu ce
serait vraiment le rêve et je ne nage
plus de chez un psychologue parce que je
pense que c'est un métier du futur avec
toutes les choses qui vont se passer sur
la tire
[Musique]
et couper c'est bon c'est bon mais qu'en
même temps ça nul mais la regarde centre
de faire mes parent est d'appuyer sur le
truc là comme ses crochets il faut
arranger à ok y'a ses origines petits
boutons mais couple à l'aide du bouton
rouge
moi j'ai mon coloc ans et bien qu'en ce
moment là c'est bon tu enlèves ta mère
on n'a pas fait mais ça se couper au
montage ça